[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf uns marietta slomka guten abend als
olaf scholz seine zeitenwende rede im
deutschen bundestag hielt stand ja
vielen erstmal der mund offen nicht
zuletzt wegen des angekündigten 100
milliarden sondervermögens für
investitionen in die deutsche
verteidigungsfähigkeit da fielen bei der
bundeswehr einige fast vom stuhl
jahrelang hatten sie geklagt über die
ausrüstungsmängel der truppe und jetzt
plötzlich ein solcher geldsegen seitdem
sind rund drei monate vergangen und
nicht nur der begriff zeitenwende ist
etwas schal geworden vorsichtig gesagt
auch über die 100 milliarden gibt es
unstimmigkeiten innerhalb der ampel
koalition und mit der union cdu/csu
müssen ja auch zustimmen wenn das
sondervermögen im grundgesetz verankert
werden soll heute sollte schließlich
eine einigung erzielt werden aus berlin
karl hinterleitner
es ist das wohl wichtigste projekt des
bundeskanzlers zu viel beschworenen
zeitenwende 100 milliarden
sondervermögen für die verteidigung
versprochen vor drei monaten
heute morgen in seinem wahlkreis in
potsdam dazu nur dünne worte olaf scholz
hofft auf eine einigung
ich hoffe dass wir jetzt die
verständigung mit der union über diese
frage hinkriegen dass wir damit auch die
finanzierung ermöglichen können doch es
gibt streit klar ist dass es 100
milliarden sein sollen aber wie und
wohin genau fließt das geld die union
wird alles ausschließlich für die
bundeswehr die grünen wollen auch mittel
in die abwehr von digitalen angriffen
stecken
sicherheits ist mehr als alleine
investitionen in die bundeswehr wir sind
zum beispiel auch sehr anfällig gegen
cyberangriffe und diese spielen eine
rolle wie nie zuvor und deswegen sagen
wir uns sagt die bundesregierung
gemeinsam das auch dafür das geld
ausgegeben werden sollte wie genau das
nato ziel zwei prozent des
bruttoinlandsprodukts für die
verteidigung auf zuwendet verankert wird
ist noch unklar für die geplante
grundgesetzänderung ist eine
zweidrittelmehrheit nötig also die
zustimmung der union doch die hat klare
bedingungen
wir haben deutlich gemacht dass die das
doppel versprechen des bundeskanzlers
das in seiner zeiten wenn die rede
abgegeben hat 100 milliarden für die
streitkräfte und dauerhafte 2 prozent
die bundeswehr zu investieren das nato
ziel zu erfüllen dass das gewährleistet
sein muss für die sozialdemokraten ist
das parteipolitisches taktieren alles
für die bundeswehr und geld gegen
cyberangriffe das sei gar kein
widerspruch mal die saskia esken heute
in berlin direkt soweit ich weiß ist die
bundeswehr in fragen der cybersicherheit
tätig also insofern wäre geld für die
bundeswehr möglicherweise auch geld für
die cyber sicherheit und die ist
dringend notwendig zu unterstützen da
bin ich ja auch fachlich ganz bei der
sache aber ganz klar ist wie gesagt
vereinbart es ist ein sondervermögen für
die bundeswehr die fdp ist bei der
genauen verwendung der 100 milliarden
verhandlungsbereit und für die heutigen
gespräche optimistisch es ist vollkommen
klar dass die bundeswehr das allermeiste
geld bekommen soll und die frage gibt es
vielleicht noch andere dinge die der
verteidigungsfähigkeit dienen die
wichtig sind für die sicherheit unseres
landes darüber muss verhandelt werden da
sind wir aber nicht so weit auseinander
deswegen würde ich auch nicht verstehen
wenn wir an diesem punkt heute keine
lösung finden werden um die lösung wird
im finanzministerium noch gerungen ein
ende scheint aber in sicht
tja eigentlich waren wir mit christian
lindner verabredet aber der steckte bis
gerade eben noch in der runde festung
konnte natürlich nicht auch einfach
vorzeitig raus schack und alabama sie
dass ich das dann doch jetzt so nochmal
in die länge zieht ist schon auch ein
zeichen dass es da ganz schön hakt oder
ja es gibt ja tatsächlich auch viel zu
klären denn dieses 100 milliarden
sondervermögens ist ja sozusagen die
basis für das zweiten wende versprechen
dass olaf scholz davor gut drei monaten
gegeben hat also muss es auch zwischen
union und ampel einvernehmlich
vereinbart werden weil eben die union
gebraucht wird für die verankerung im
grundgesetz und die ampel hat da nicht
nur mit der union gerungen jetzt rein
sondern eben auch mit sich selbst das
haben wir gerade im stück schon
angedeutet gehört die grünen vor allem
wollten sich nicht auf einen ganz engen
verteidigungsbegriff festlegen lassen
bei dem es dann nur um rüstungsausgaben
geht sondern wollten eben auch
sicherstellen dass in cyber sicherheit
und auch in bündnispartner investiert
werden kann wir sehen jetzt gerade heute
ein wenig bewegung da jetzt ist die
frage gibt es nur ist es nur eine frage
der formulierung oder haben sich
wirklich beide seiten aufeinander
zubewegt also hat auch die union
zugeständnisse gemacht es ging nämlich
auch noch um die frage es sind diese 100
milliarden dann bestandteil des
versprochenen jährlichen 2 prozent ziels
der nato was man erfüllen möchte oder
kommt es nach oben drauf also viele
fragen die zu klären sind wir warten
eigentlich minütlich auf ein statement
das haben wir heute schon gehört dass
soll es noch geben und das deutet
zumindest darauf hin dass man eine
einigung sehr nah ist dann schauen wir
mal vielleicht passiert ja wir haben
unsere sendung noch war es dank konnten
derweil tobt in der ukraine weiter der
krieg die russische armee hat sie ihre
taktik geändert hat ihre ziele reduziert
konzentriert sich auf bestimmte orte und
fronten im donbass und lässt da dann
aber massiv aufmarschieren die ukraine
stehen dort unter dauerbeschuss mit
schwerster artillerie und auch angriffen
aus der luft nach ukrainischen angaben
werden von den russen auch thermo
bayerische waffen eingesetzt so genannte
vakuumpumpen mit furchtbarer
großflächiger zerstörungskraft
umso drängender die bitten der ukraine
um schwere waffen und
flugabwehrsysteme dominik löschmeister
berichtet
wolodimir selensky auf front suchen hf
seit kriegsbeginn ist der ukrainische
präsident zum ersten mal außerhalb der
region kiew unterwegs sie lenski
verschafft sich einen eindruck von den
zerstörungen der russischen angreifer
die ukrainische armee hatte die
russischen truppen aus der region um
krakau zurückgedrängt die aufnahmen
verbreitet über den offiziellen
telegramm kanal des präsidenten zeigen
auch wie sie lenski soldaten auszeichnen
ich möchte jeden von ihnen für ihren
dienst danken sie riskieren ihr leben
für uns alle und für unseren staat
danke dass sie die unabhängigkeit
unseres landes verteidigen
besonders umkämpft ist die großstadt
zefiro donezk im don was das russische
militär soll die ostukrainische stadt
fast komplett umstellt haben laut
ukrainischem generalstab da waren die
kämpfe in der region an die russen
hätten die stadt noch nicht unter
kontrolle
für die menschen bleibt nur die flucht
aus dem kampfgebiet jana und ihre kinder
hielten sich zweieinhalb monate fast nun
keller auf doch die lage vor ort ist
immer gefährlicher
lange wollte ich nicht gehen keiner von
uns wollte seine heimatstadt verlassen
doch der kleinen kinder wegen haben wir
beschlossen zu gehen
fast unter tage geht dieser krieg in der
ukraine inzwischen umso dringender
fordert kiew eine rasche lieferung
nach baldigen verhandlungen sieht es
jedenfalls nicht aus wobei die
telefondiplomatie von olaf scholz und
dem manuel makau übrigens auch nicht
überall in europa gut ankommt die
ministerpräsident ist lanz etwa kajak
ahlers hält es derzeit für
kontraproduktiv mit putin zu reden wenn
man wolle dass er spürt wie er sein land
isoliert sollte man ihn nicht ständig
anrufen
russland zu isolieren und finanziell
unter druck zu setzen dazu sollen vor
allem die sanktions pakete der eu den
heute gibt es in brüssel erneut große
anstrengungen alle 27 einschließlich
ungarn zumindest auf ein öl embargo
einzuschwören davon berichtet anne
gellinek
öl-embargo jetzt fordert ein häuflein
demonstranten vor dem gipfel gebäude in
brüssels europaviertel am abend da wo ab
morgen die 27 staats und regierungschefs
und chefinnen sitzen werden versuchen
heute ihre unterhändler das verflixte
sechste sanktionspaket zu beschließen
seit vier wochen liegt es auf dem tisch
sein kern ein embargo für russisches öl
über dass europa sich gerade zerstreitet
wolodimir selensky will sich morgen zum
eu-gipfel zu schalten lassen und wird
eine harte und vor allem geschlossene
haltung der europäer einfordern nur dass
das mit der einigkeit gerade immer
komplizierter wird
wir waren von uns selbst überrascht wie
schnell wir europäer bislang reagiert
haben aber jetzt machen wir uns sorgen
wegen der öl sanktionen schaffen wir es
uns auf ein sechstes paket mit öl
embargo gegen russland zu einigen wir
wissen dass einige länder einwände haben
aber ich hoffe wir können diese nuss
knacken
ungarn wehrt sich bislang am heftigsten
lehnt auch eine zweijährige
übergangsfrist ab der grund ist die
druschba pipeline übersetzt freundschaft
ihren ort versorgt deutschland mit
russischem öl an der südlichen röhre
hängt die energieversorgung von ungarn
der slowakei und tschechien
alle drei länder haben keinen meeres
zugang und fordern nun ausnahmen deshalb
wird jetzt über ein abgespecktes
öl-embargo diskutiert dass nur öl
betrifft das pad tanker nach europa
kommt aber auch darauf konnten sich die
27 europäer bislang nicht einigen
tatsächlich liefert russland ungefähr 70
prozent seines rohöls per tanker über
die ostsee richtung westeuropa
hauptsächlich nach rotterdam über das
schwarze meer nach südeuropa in den
hafen von triest prompt die kritik an
einem abgeschwächten embargo es geht ja
darum dass man ein öl-embargo gegen
russland macht und das macht nur sinn in
dem man dann auch alle staaten beteiligt
und wege findet wie man alternativen zum
russischen öl findet und genau darum
muss es jetzt ergeben dass man nicht
einzelne abschnitte herausnimmt oder
ausnahmen er wird uneinigkeit auch beim
thema eu beitritt der ukraine
während sich die osteuropäer den
sofortigen kandidatenstatus wünschen
versuchen die westeuropäer inklusive
deutschland eher zu bremsen und dann
wäre da noch der umgang mit wladimir
putin scholz und makro wollen den dialog
aufrechterhalten balten und polen lieber
nur mit der ukraine reden
morgen beginnt ein eu gipfel bei dem
offener streit über das öl-embargo fast
unausweichlich ist und allen ist klar je
länger der krieg dauert desto mehr wird
europas zusammenhalt bröckelt
und jetzt erstmal die nachrichten von
hans wolf einen sondierungs papier haben
cdu und grüne in nordrhein westfalen
schon erarbeitet heute kam nun auch
grünes licht für die aufnahme von
koalitionsverhandlungen von den
jeweiligen parteigremien der erweiterte
cdu landesvorstand und ein parteirat der
grünen stimmten zu beginnen sollen die
koalitionsverhandlungen am dienstag
teilte ministerpräsident wüst mit
bundesarbeitsminister hey lehnt eine
erhöhung des
renteneintrittsalters ab er halte es für
eine phantomdebatte des 70 arbeiten zu
wollen oder zu sollen sagte er halte
funke mediengruppe das sei eine
diskussion die mit der lebensrealität
vieler menschen in deutschland nicht zu
vereinbaren sei
er widersprach damit ökonomen die sich
wegen der hohen inflation für eine
anhebung des renteneintrittsalters
ausgesprochen hatten
mit appellen für eine tiefgreifende
kirchenreform und mehr anstrengungen für
den klimaschutz ist der 100 zweite
deutsche katholikentag in stuttgart zu
ende gegangen im schlussgottesdienst
wurde auch für die menschen in der
ukraine gebetet die unter dem russischen
angriffskrieg leiden an dem fünftägigen
katholikentag nahmen rund 27.000
gläubige teil deutlich weniger als beim
letzten treffen
und mehr zum katholikentag in stuttgart
gibt es im zdf auch in einer reportage
unter dem titel zwischen krieg und
frieden und zwar um 0.35 hier im
programm und jetzt schon in der
mediathek
nach dem amoklauf an einer grundschule
im us bundesstaat texas ist präsident
biden nach vivaldi gereist vor der
schule legten er und seine frau jill
einen blumenstrauß nieder im anschluss
trafen sie angehörige der opfer und
überlebende in der gemeinde schlägt die
trauer immer mehr in wut um der vorwurf
die polizei habe die schule zu spät
gestürmt 19 kinder und zwei lehrerinnen
wurden von einem 18 jährigen schützen
getötet
er schwarz fährt begeht ein delikt mal
kann das passieren aber wir immer wieder
ohne ticket aufgegriffen wird sollte
dafür auch bestraft werden klingt
erstmal einleuchtend aber die realität
sieht vielfach dann doch etwas anders
aus wie christian von rechenberg in
seinem bericht gleich zeigt und die
strafverfolgung in der bisherigen form
führt dazu dass in den gefängnissen
hierzulande erstaunlich viele menschen
sitzen also die verhängten geldstrafen
nicht bezahlten wie sinnvoll das ist
darüber wird in justizkreisen schon
länger debattiert und nicht nur
bundesjustizminister buschmann plädiert
dafür dass zumindest die zahl derer die
wegen schwarzfahren in haft kommen
reduziert wird
schämt sich was er gemacht hat war nicht
in ordnung sagt er rückblickend was man
mit ihm gemacht hat auch nicht seinen
namen sollen wir nicht nennen er wurde
erwischt ohne ticket in der bahn nicht
einmal sich mal das ist in deutschland
eine straftat § 265 a stgb erschleichen
von leistungen brachte herrn o ins
gefängnis
insgesamt waren es rund dreieinhalb
jahre
also dreieinhalb jahre verteilt auch für
einzelne oft strafen doch kein richter
hatte herrn o jemals zu haft verurteilt
alle vier verfahren endeten mit einer
geldstrafe und einem problem also wenn
ich so viel geld gehabt hätte und die
geldstrafen bezahlen zu können dann
hätte ich ja auch wie schwarzfahren
brauchen perron ist schwer krank als er
davon erfuhr brach sein leben zusammen
sagt er obdachlosigkeit depression armut
geldstrafen zahlen kann er nicht sie
abarbeiten auch nicht und nun schreibt
das strafrecht vor wer die geldstrafe
nicht zahlt muss in haft
ersatzfreiheitsstrafe sie soll
abschrecken das prinzip ist auch
einleuchtend
zum problem wird es dann wenn die leute
nicht bezahlen können obwohl sie wollen
wenn leute dann solchen event leben
obdachlose drogenabhängige leute die
unter psychischen krankheiten leiden das
ist beim besten willen nicht gestemmt
bekommen dann wird strafen wir
eigentlich nicht die schwere ihrer tat
über strafen eigentlich elend aber auch
wie viele trifft das wirklich zu nicole
bögelein ist einer der wenigen die da zu
forschen von denjenigen die wirklich
wegen schwarzfahrens in
ersatzfreiheitsstrafe kommen ist der
meister der größte anteil in einem
desolaten zustand was das leben
anbelangt rund 650.000 menschen so
bürgel einsitzen aufs jahr gerechnet
wegen einer geldstrafe in haft sie sind
damit erstmals die größte gruppe für sie
gibt der staat pro hafttag 150 euro aus
mit dem geld könnte sozialarbeit viel
besser helfen sagt man uns in einer
beratungsstelle für straffällige oft
mache alles nur noch schlimmer
das danach einfach wieder von vorne
losgeht also dass man eventuell die
wohnung verloren hat es gibt keine
leistungen es gibt keine arbeit es gibt
viele viele diverse problemen die nach
der haft entstehen renault hat die haft
immer wieder zurückgeworfen sagte
zurzeit geht es ihm besser wäre sein
leben ohne ersatzfreiheitsstrafe anders
verlaufen
was ist um den faktor 100 einfache
gewissen schätze ich mal ich wäre nicht
mehrfach einschlägig vorbestraft ich
hätte erheblich weniger schulden eine
lösung wäre das fahren ohne fahrschein
keine straftat mehr ist abschaffung des
paragraphen 265 a stgb das wollen selbst
richter vollzugsbeamte es steht sogar im
koalitionsvertrag wir fragen nach beim
bundesjustizminister dann setzen sie das
um antwort wir prüfen noch
nächste woche feiert königin elizabeth
ihr 70 das thronjubiläum
sie prägt natürlich in besonderer form
unser england bild der buckingham palace
das teure london oder auch die miss
marple bzw rosamunde pilcher mäßigen
landschafts idylle aber
es gibt auch ein ganz anderes england
vor allem der norden ist vielerorts
bitterarm und erschreckend verwahrlost
das ist nicht ganz neu manchester etwa
wurde mit dem begriff manchester
kapitalismus schon im neunzehnten
jahrhundert berüchtigt als synonym für
ausbeutung und kinderarbeit den
zwanzigsten jahrhundert brachte die
schließung nordenglische bergwerke große
armut witzig und jetzt sind es pandemie
rezession doch praxis die den menschen
das leben noch schwerer machen als es
das zuvor schon war diana zimmermann
berichtet
spielerisch lernt reilly hier fürs leben
einmal die woche kommt er in die kirche
im nordenglischen burnley
was magst du hier am liebsten
das essen
[Musik]
immer mehr familien in großbritannien
wissen nicht mehr wie sie heizen oder
essen sollen patrick fühlt sich längst
weniger zuständig für das seelenheil als
für das nackte überleben seiner
gemeindemitglieder
wir spüren und ihr sehen richtige armut
in einem ausmaß wie ich es nie zuvor in
meinem leben gesehen habe
aus unserer perspektive scheint es dass
die traditionellen weltlichen
organisationen immer mehr leute zu uns
schicken weil sie keine ressourcen haben
zehn jahre sparpolitik haben die
staatlichen leistungen gefährlich
ausgedünnt dann kamen der brh exit und
die pandemie inzwischen hat die
inflation 9 prozent erreicht und die
energiekosten steigen immer weiter
patricks kirche betreibt eine tafel vor
allem mit spenden aus dem reichen süden
des landes
wenn die leute kein gas haben können sie
sich auch nichts kochen bank brauchen
sie auch keine lebensmittel burgs
opposition und
wohltätigkeitsorganisationen schlagen
seit monaten alarm fordern not zahlungen
für die armen zu denen in großbritannien
übrigens jeder fünfte zählt lange hat
der finanzminister selbst einer der
reichsten männer des landes gezögert
vergangene woche dann entschied er die
großen öl und gasunternehmen extra zu
besteuern um die schlimmste
lebenshaltungs krise seit 70 jahren
abzufedern können so in der regierung
kann jedes problem lösen schon gar nicht
das komplexe und globale problem der
inflation aber diese regierung wird nie
aufhören zu versuchen menschen zu helfen
das gesamtpaket umfasst gut 17
milliarden euro doch viele im land
glauben selbst das wird nicht reichen um
weitere verelendung zu verhindern das
ganze politische system so fürchtet
pater mit droht seine glaubwürdigkeit
vollends zu verlieren wenn nicht für
mehr gerechtigkeit gesorgt wird was hier
passiert vor allem im norden englands
ist eine düstere warnung für den rest
europas sollte sein sie sollten nach
großbritannien schauen sich anschauen wo
die wirtschaft steht sich anschauen wie
viele menschen hier sterben obdachlos
sind psychisch krank und so weiter und
das als eine warnung begreifen
london bereitet sich auf die feiern zum
70 thronjubiläum der queen vor doch
selten spielen die unterschiede zwischen
arm und reich in ihrem königreich so
sehr zum himmel wie gerade jetzt
diana zimmermann als reportage armes
königreich können sie mittwochnacht
sehen und in der mediathek abrufen und
jetzt eins mit den sport an diesem
wochenende das finale der fußball
champions league hat auch jenseits des
sportlichen triumphs von real madrid für
schlagzeilen gesorgt über das 1 0 und
die vorkommnisse vor dem spiel in paris
berichtet michael kreutz
chaos vor dem spiel an den eingängen des
stade de france fans versuchen über den
zaun ins stadion zu kommen andere wütend
dahinter wallaus sie trotz ticket
offenbar nicht rechtzeitig reingelassen
werden es ist absolut chaotisch die
franzosen ihre organisation und die uefa
einfach schrecklich die uefa vermutet
die verbreitung gefälschter tickets sei
auslöser für die massiven einlass
probleme gewesen auch der französische
innenminister macht auf twitter die
britischen fans ohne tickets für das
chaos verantwortlich und bedankte sich
bei den sicherheitskräften
die greifen hart durch aber laut aussage
begleitender englische polizisten läge
die schuld nicht bei den fans von der
insel erst mit 36 minuten verspätung
wird angepfiffen liverpool über weite
strecken überlegen kann aber courtois
den überragenden torwart der madrilenen
nicht überwinden anders real der einzige
treffer des spiels durch vinicius junior
real madrid wird zum vierzehnten mal
champions-league-sieger feierstimmung
auch heute in madrid aber genauso in
liverpool
bei den french open steht alexander
zverev im viertelfinale durch einen
dreisatzsieg gegen den spanischen
qualifikanten zapata mehr als
zur formel1 sergio perez hat den großen
preis von monaco gewonnen regen hatte
den start um mehr als eine stunde
verzögert und später dann wieder eine
unterbrechung mit schumacher verlor die
kontrolle über seinen wagen blieb aber
unverletzt nach einem chaotischen rennen
kam perez ganz knapp als erster über die
ziellinie vor covers 1 und weltmeister
max verstecken
herr sandra orschel aus hamburg ist die
überraschungssiegerin des deutschen
spring derby erstmals seit 47 jahren hat
damit wieder eine reiterin hier gewonnen
sie setzte sich bei der 91 auflage des
klassikers in hamburg klein flottbek auf
der cara durch als einziges der vier
paare im stechen blieben die für polen
startende reiterin und ihre stute
fehlerfrei
zweiter wurde frederic tillmann aus
grevenbroich
[Applaus]
putins angriffskrieg hat die ukraine
näher an europa heran gerückt und das
ist durchaus beidseitig die viele
berichterstattung über die ukraine haben
viele deutsche mehr über dieses land
erfahren sein menschen landschaften
städte geschichte an blinden flecken
mangelte es uns daher durchaus nicht
auch das hatte es putin erleichtert
seine vorherigen aktionen durchzuziehen
aber inzwischen scheint europa
aufgewacht in diesem sinne durchaus
starkes signal war da zuletzt dass das
europäische publikum beim eurovision
songcontest geradezu einhellig für die
ukraine stimmte und die siegerband
carlos orchestra konnte man heute neben
anderen am brandenburger tor live
erleben bei einem großen benefizkonzert
für die ukraine stefanie dosch und lore
müller waren in berlin dabei
vor dem symbol des friedens dem
brandenburger tor das ukrainische
benefizkonzert am tag der stadt kiel
[Musik]
okra ina weller russen deutsche tausende
kamen
[Musik]
für mich zeigt dass hier das die
menschen dass die welt uns unterstützt
ich bin wirklich dankbar
ich glaube es ist sehr wichtig auch das
ist symbolisch wichtig berlin und kiel
heute zusammen zu verbinden heute ist
der kirchtag und es ist für uns nicht
möglich zu hause zu sein so sind wir
gekommen um uns mit menschen zu
verbinden und unsere musik zu hören den
spurt der ukraine zu führen
18 ukrainische künstlerinnen und
künstler treten dafür auf live
übertragen vom ukrainischen fernsehen
und weiteren 20 sendern der eintritt in
berlin frei
wir wollen das künstlerische gesicht der
ukraine zeigen außerdem wollen wir daran
erinnern dass der krieg in der ukraine
mitten in europa tobt und wir wollen
natürlich geld sammeln für humanitäre
zwecke für medizinische zwecke es fehlen
etwa mobile röntgengeräte für
ukrainische krankenhäusern
sie hoffen auf spenden zwei stunden
dauert das benefizkonzert auch mit
videos internationaler künstlerinnen und
künstler und grußbotschaften viele
regierungschefs auch des bundeskanzlers
ukraine wir stehen an eurer seite wir
stehen geeint für die ukraine für
freiheit rechtsstaatlichkeit und würde
als europäische schwestern und brüder
european systems and models
musikalisches highlight vor wenigen
minuten carlos orchestra mit ihrem lied
stefanie
es ist etwas ganz besonderes hier an
diesem symbolischen ort aufzutreten wir
hoffen viele menschen zu erreichen und
ihnen zu zeigen dass wir weiter hilfe
brauchen
es ist ihre art für ihr land zu kämpfen
die nachricht die ukraine steht fest
zusammen aber braucht jede unterstützung
auch heute in berlin am tag von kiew
[Musik]
der krieg in der ukraine wird es
natürlich auch nächste woche umtreiben
mit all den unvorhersehbarkeiten die mit
solchen kriegen einhergehen auf andere
vorhersehbare ereignisse und termine
schauen wir jeden sonntag in unserem
wochenausblick und den hat heute laura
panik erstellt
[Musik]
ab mittwoch können fahrgäste drei monate
lang mit dem neuen euro ticket durch
deutschland fahren die bundesregierung
will die bevölkerung angesichts der
inflation entlasten und die
attraktivität öffentlicher
verkehrsmittel steigern zusätzlich soll
der sogenannte tank rabatt die sprit
preise senken
70 jahre ist es her dass elisabeth die
zweite zur queen gekrönt wurde ab
donnerstag wird das platin
dienstjubiläum vier tage lang gefeiert
mit 96 jahren ist elisabeth die zweite
nicht nur die am längsten herrschende
sondern gleichzeitig derzeit auch die
weltweit älteste monarchen
am donnerstag werden die un-staaten zum
50 jährigen jubiläum der welt
umweltkonferenz in stockholm zusammen
kommen eine studie des club of rome
hatte
1972 die diskussion um den klimaschutz
entfacht seitdem bemüht sich die un das
engagement für nachhaltigkeit zu fördern
und die globalen umwelt ziele umzusetzen
und noch die wetteraussichten zum start
in die neue woche morgen wechseln sonne
und wolken an den alpen und im nordosten
gibt es schauer und kurze gewitter
zwischen main und donau ist es länger
sonnig die temperatur erreicht 13 bis 21
grad ab dienstag wird es jeden tag ein
bisschen wärmer am donnerstag sind es 18
bis 28 grad zwar zeigt sich oft die
sonne ein paar schauer und gewitter gibt
es aber doch die meisten im süden
das war's für uns hat diesem
sonntagabend weitergeht vielleicht mit
dem schweden krimi mord im mit server
und um 0.30 gibt es dann die nächste
heute express und hier erwarten sie
morgen abend bettina schausten und
gundula gause auf wiedersehen auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]